you might have heard Kirsten Nielsen is
out as Homeland Security Secretary
president Trump doubles down on his
crackdown at the border US Customs and
Border Protection Commissioner Kevin
McHale enan will become the acting DHS
secretary this comes as the president is
reportedly planning a massive overhaul
to fix the crisis he tweeted more
apprehensions captures at the southern
border than in many years border patrol
amazing country is full system has been
broken for many years Democrats in
Congress must agree to fix loopholes no
open borders crimes and drugs will close
southern border if necessary Democrats
are seizing on the news and criticizing
Nielsen for her time as Secretary watch
this for the rest of her life people
will look at her and think oh that's the
woman who put children in cages that's
the woman who broke up families across
the border and you know what they'll be
right she has been a disgrace as
Secretary of Homeland Security and she
leaves behind a legacy of separating
families caging children you almost have
to feel sorry for Nielsen I don't feel
sorry for but almost because you know
she is willing to violate the dictates
of humanity morality and ethics but
she's not actually willing to break the
law
Kirsten Nielsen will be known for
implementing a cruel policy of forcibly
separating parents and children but
White House deputy press secretary Hogan
Gidley says this just proves that
Democrats priorities are not on
protecting the homeland I do find it
kind of interesting that the media is so
focused on what happened behind the
scenes with the resignation of secretary
Nielsen instead of worrying about what's
actually happening at the border and we
have a crisis down there an emergency
and the media refuses to focus on that
but instead wants to talk about palace
intrigue enacting White House chief of
staff Mick Mulvaney also doubling down
on the criticism of Democrats handling
of immigration in fact I know it's hard
to imagine but again Nancy Pelosi runs
the Democrats in Congress Mexico has
done more in the last week to help our
illegal immigration crisis than Nancy
Pelosi and Democrats in the house with
so that's been a pretty good week all
right we're gonna take it around the
table I've got to start with you Greg
yes I just find it richly ironic when
Jeffrey Toobin accuses anybody of
breaking up families so anyway and the
other thing is let's remember where that
story started when those pick
first came out in the media on Twitter
those are pictures that were from the
time when President Obama was president
so this was a problem that was the
splitting up of families that was shared
by both families this is the first time
in probably recent history that we have
a non-politician trying to solve a
problem that was shared by both parties
we can agree that this is a responsible
I mean this is the responsibility of
Democrats and Republicans okay you got
to look at Trump as a general manager of
a sports team the situations are not
dictated by the players right the
players are dictated by the situation so
when the situation requires a fix he
replaces people to affect the situation
so it's like baseball if the current
lineup isn't working you say is you
bench the guy or you get rid of the guy
you trade the guy for somebody else
that's all he does and he sees if it
works and again and I've said this
before the person who takes the long
term solution will never be treated
sympathetically long term solutions are
always seem harsh in the short term you
know the media or the media are the
children who want ice cream for
breakfast
right the the Trump is the parent saying
no you know what to be a healthy adult
you're gonna have to eat like this super
great eat your greens
the what what Trump is trying to do is
affect the long term solution that that
will remain that way after he's out of
office knowing that he's sacrificing so
much capital everybody hates him for
being the parent the media especially
because they're the children the
children who basically push this lie
that it was the this was the first
administration to separate families it
is the truth no hang on the truth is
that Obama was dealing with
unaccompanied minors here you have
families so you have moms and children
who were separated by Nielsen and why
again I think that it's not only is it
illegal it's unethical and immoral say
no in the same like I'm just saying now
that with strangers it's just not true
what you said but I'm gonna say no it
was working perfectly it wasn't working
we have a different kind of issue now
with so many
families and children well I families
why why because and again I just want to
say does this does all that he's done
make you feel safer getting rid of
Nielsen getting rid of the Secret
Service it seems to me this is so
dangerous in terms of our national
security we saw today from the brain
room this guy has more cabinet positions
gone and everybody going way back I mean
sick and on immigration Katie your
thoughts of course
Kirsten Nielsen I think in some ways was
in an impossible situation right she's
confined by the law right Brendan
doesn't like the law a lot of people
don't like the law but Congress won't
fix the law yeah and so she wasn't able
to be tougher in the way that he wanted
so as Greg said maybe you changed the
player this has been a long time coming
this was not some rash decision that
President Trump made Kirsten Nielsen has
been on the rocks for a long time with
President Trump she's been able to
solidify her position for a couple of
months but this is something that was
inevitably going to come it's very
difficult for any Department of Homeland
Security Secretary to do anything more
than they're doing now with this influx
of people due to the way the system is
set up with the catch and release now
there is hope with maca llenan because
he does have a good relationship with
people on Capitol Hill he worked for
Barack Obama and was on the frontlines
of this crisis when it started in 2014
and - as - Greg said the photos that
everybody was saying belong to the Obama
administration about the children being
in cages those were from 2014 and we at
town hall and at Breitbart were from the
only reporters in the entire media who
were actually publishing those photos
and warning about the crisis that was
coming so Matt Kalinin has seen this
from the beginning he knows what needs
to be done and hopefully he can work
with committees like the Senate
Judiciary Committee where the attorneys
they're working on immigration know what
needs to be fixed so they can actually
come up with something to change this
and one more thing you know all these
Democrats are talking about how horrible
kirsten nielsen was but she was a
terrible person for separating parents
and children well if you break the law
in America and go to prison you get
separated from your family first of all
second of all what is their solution
there's their name-calling a whole lot
but they're not putting any legislation
on the on the table to actually solve
the problem which sets up a talking
point for them for years to come in 1020
years when you're saying all these
children were brought here by their
parents illegally should we have a
dreamer program
from them as well it's a whole nother
system that they're setting up it's in
political capital that they are are
engaging off of right now Jesse in the
time we have Emmanuel give you the floor
think about it for a second you have
America the greatest country on the face
of the earth that can't stop foreigners
from coming here and staying here
because of dumb laws and Dumber
politicians we're erasing our own
borders ourselves if you think about it
person in Central America grab a kid
your kid any kid doesn't matter hop on a
caravan come up north set one foot in
Texas and we can't do anything about it
your kid who's ever it is that you're
bringing there they're a dreamer their
kid
they're gonna be a citizen you yourself
you go to California you're gonna get
welfare you get a driver's license
you're gonna get health care you commit
a felony I get the pail one's even going
to deport you you can do whatever you
want so the Democrats they want this
situation to be satis quo they don't
care about families being separated if
they did they'd do something to fix it
Pelosi had an opportunity herself when
she cut the deal with Trump
last month did she offer an asylum fix a
detention fix she offered literally
nothing except a few more beds so when
the Democrats talk don't listen to him I
don't even hear what they're saying
look what they're doing and they're
absolutely doing nothing to cut the beds
remember they tried to cut the know what
you take a look at what the Republicans
what Trump's doing it seems to me that
whenever Trump runs into a complex
situation he has a simple solution and
he decides that he wants to go beyond
the law and that's what happened with
Kirsten Nielsen she went in there
yesterday afternoon at five o'clock she
didn't turn to resign and he's telling
her stop this just stop people from
applying for asylum kick people out get
rid of the judges get rid of the judge
again one has a solution all he did oh
yeah sure I have solutions I'm going
over them last you what they were last
week I told you when I saw your party
has no solution that's not true
everybody agrees we need more detention
facilities more judges we need more
producer yelling at me anymore because
of you all right